more than 70 United Nations Aid workers
have been killed in Gaza since October
7th when the current hostilities began
on Friday here at the UN Martin
Griffiths the top un humanitarian
official became emotional when he began
speaking about those
losses one of the terrible things about
that those killings are that most of
them have happened in the homes of those
people and they have been killed with
their families
I think it's the highest number of
un staff lost in a
conflict the United Nations is providing
shelter for more than
650,000 displaced people in Gaza but an
official said that the bombardment by
Israel has become so intense even the
United Nations cannot guarantee the
safety of the people that need it the
most we've had over 50 of our facilities
that have been impacted by the conflict
including five direct hits I think at
last count 38 people have
died uh in our
shelters I fear that with the fighting
going on in the north right now that is
that number is going to grow
significantly these are people seeking
shelter under a un flag seeking
protection uh under International
humanitarian law the UN reports in the
last 10 days a total of 329 Aid trucks
have reached Gaza through the Rafa
Crossing but officials say that's not
nearly enough before October 7th about
500 Aid trucks got to Gaza every single
day Gabriel zando Al jazer at the United
Nations make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer